io sto parlando principalmente ai
bambini e non vi fate ingannare non
guardate in giro quanti nomi ci sono
nella
ce ne sono un paio di minuti ma io sto
parlando a tutti i bambini presenti e
passati ai vostri bambini ai bambini che
siete stati ai bambini che avete
smarrito ai bambini che state
disperatamente cercando di ritrovare la
chiave della dul titta la chiave del
successo alla realizzazione personale
del benessere risiede nell'infanzia e
può iniziare la storia la mia storia
inizia quando il 19 anni a 19 anni era
un adolescente abbastanza ribelle il mio
desiderio era come molti adolescenti
ribelli della provincia fuggire andare
non so in cina e l'india pareti fare
cose grandiosi quasi rimango incinta e
quindi vengo zavorrata qui nella
provincia delle marche
e a quel punto vado molto molto giù vado
negli abissi perché vivo dell'esperienza
abbastanza tragiche in realtà devo anche
dire che sono fuggita di casa sono
tornata a casa che era al quinto mese
gravidanza ho vissuto tutta questa
esperienza in totale solitudine e ho
capito che la scuola non era servito a
niente
quello che affronti appena uscita da
scuola e la vita e nessuno ti prepara a
gestirla quell evenienza
quell'eventualità quelle esperienze che
potrebbero essere anche drammatiche
laceranti
in quel momento ho avuto un guizzo un
lampo è la sensazione è stata quella di
essere stata lanciata scaraventata
dentro una piscina però quando arrivi
giù giù giù in fondo che tocchi l'abisso
tipo dare la spinta e torni fuori e io
sento che sono riuscito a darmi quella
spintina e riemergere e quel punto mi
sono iniziato a guardare intorno a dire
cavolo fa veramente schifo non c'è
niente qui è una figata se comprare
qualsiasi cosa e da lì è nato il mio
desiderio di fare qualcosa per la
comunità per l'infanzia
io sento che le nostre esistenze hanno
uno scopo hanno un senso solo se
collegate con quelle degli altri è
inutile secondo me pensare non solo in
questo momento storico vedo che c'è una
grande auto celebrazione si
l'imprenditore di sé street e stesso
riesce ci dà solo farcela e poi perché
ci fai questa cosa se non l'hai fatto
per gli altri
quindi ho deciso che avrei dedicato la
mia totale esistenza agli altri in
particolare piccoli che secondo me sono
la pagina bianca dell'umanità sì ci sono
arredamenti che ha dappertutto
si rivede davvero i bambini chi davvero
li rispetta chi davvero li tratta come
esseri umani chi non li minaccia chi non
li punisce chi non li maltratta una
minoranza e la minoranza è perché ha
lavorato sulla propria infanzia tutto
quello che voi fate con i bambini è
quello che avete ricevuto il passaggio
cruciale è elaborare il lutto della
propria infanzia che una percepisce che
in parte può essere stata sciupata e
quindi ho aperto una scuola comunità
dinamica prima di aprire una scuola
fatta una riflessione la scuola per me è
la risposta educativa ai problemi
sociali di ciascun epoca che significa
che se ne andiamo analizzare quelle che
sono state le varie tipologie di scuole
che ci sono state fino a questo momento
le colleghiamo quello che è stato il
panorama storico culturale politico di
quell'epoca esempio lo sapete qual è la
storia della scuola italiana perché c'è
questa frase bellissima che tutti
diciamo la scuola nostro diritto che
vuol dire quando è nata la scuola perché
è nata la scuola la scuola come noi la
conosciamo cioè la scuola statale è nata
durante l'unificazione d'italia c'è la
frase fatta l'italia si fanno gli
italiani ve lo ricordate è stato messo
un passaggio
fatta l'italia facciamo gli italiani ma
perché dovevano fare gli italiani
avevano bisogno dell'esercito
quindi ti insegnava a leggere scrivere e
ti insegnano a scuola che se muore in
guerra 18 anni verrà proclamato eroe
nazionale è tutta la tua famiglia sarà
orgogliosi te anche la tua città altro
quartiere che meraviglia
questo davvero i bambini studiavano sui
libri io vi invito ad andare a fare un
viaggio nella letteratura d'epoca
dell'infanzia è agghiacciante
poi la scuola serviva per modificare la
propria posizione sociale era un
ascensore sociale
io nasco figlio di contadino mi posso
emancipare possa diventare un medico
wow posso cambiare la mia posizione e
quindi aveva proprio ruolo da ascensore
poi la scuola serviva per entrare per
accedere all'interno di un meccanismo
economico sociale che aveva solidità
criteri chiari e
in questo momento adesso qual è il ruolo
della scuola io sono partita per darmi
la risposta dal paradigma della società
liquida di bauman mi sono immaginata
questo grande vassoio piano d'acqua con
qualcuno che faceva così e io ho visto
tutte quelle piccole molecole d'acqua
che giravano come gli adulti come
genitori e ho visto tanta fragilità
tanto smarrimento e poi ho immaginato
delle isole delle isole nelle quali
c'erano in spiaggia dei bagnini che ogni
tanto lancia uno dei salvagenti e io
così che via della scuola per me la
scuola in questo momento un punto di
riferimento sociale emotivo e
comunitario i professionisti
dell'educazione dovrebbero dare una mano
ai genitori a tutti gli adulti a
recuperare le loro infanzia ea vedere i
bambini che hanno di fronte
quindi per me la scuola in questo
momento ha un ruolo principalmente
sociale certo educativo in regata
all'istruzione ma principalmente sociale
nella nostra scuola
ci sono delle caratteristiche prima di
elencare vele intanto voglio specificare
perché l'abbiamo chiamata scuola
comunità dinamica scuola perché dopo
aver passato anni a chiamarla realtà
sperimentazione esperienza quasi a
vergognarmi che faceva una scuola
diversa da quella statale ha rivendicato
il mio diritto no sto facendo una scuola
non bisogna trovare altre parole ci sono
delle parole bellissime vanno riempiti
di contenuti forse diversi e quindi
scuola e anche per ricordare a tutte le
persone che ci lavorano che hanno un
compito culturale e di istruzione verso
i bambini che ci vengono affidati
comunità e per ricordare ai bambini ai
genitori e gli insegnanti che siamo
sempre in una comunità che non esiste il
faccio quello che mi pare è l'essere
centralissimi riuscire a capire
perfettamente quello che tagliano e
dentro se non percepisci quello che
avviene anche dentro gli altri se non
percepisci che tutto quello che fai ha
delle ricadute nel bene e nel male verso
il mondo che hai accanto e dinamica
perché ho deciso di rivendicare la mia
indipendenza el indipendenza della
scuola io sono passata dall'essere
montessoriana poi sono entrate nel mondo
libertario
ho girato all'interno di vari metodi
approcci e nessuno mi sembrava che
davvero rispettasse il bambino
perché un metodo solitamente è un
pacchetto chiuso ha delle
caratteristiche specifiche che
riguardano la visione del bambino le
metodologie dispositivi utilizzati i
risultati attesi e non è così l'infanzia
e che ci ha bambini lo sa
avrete studiati ma non avrete letto
qualcosa per conoscere davanti non sai
più dove mettere le mani
dinamica è per rivendicare la nostra
indipendenza di fronte ai metodi noi non
sposiamo
niente prendiamo ispirazione da tutto
però ci lasciamo guidare dai bambini
come adesso in me sta lasciando guidare
dei vostri sguardi dalle vostre facce e
dinamico e anche perché è un sinonimo di
relazioni voi non dite quelle persone
hanno una dinamica conflittuale a una
dinamica solidale ecco dinamica è una
parola chiave perché a scuola tutto
quello che facciamo è lavorare sulle
dinamiche sottese le relazioni un
bambino che ha difficoltà e tensioni
emotive non studierà un insegnante che
entra in risonanza con la storia di un
bambino non lo aiuterà a stare bene
vi dico in segreto non a tutte le
insegnanti che sono tutti i bambini anzi
alle insegnanti non piacciono tutti i
bambini ma non è alcuni bambini pulsano
sono fastidiosi che alcuni bambini ti
ricordano che hai dei problemi tuoi e te
li metterò tiri girano proprio su e sete
non li vuoi vedere i tuoi problemi vi
siete il bambino c'è problemi
la scuola non è obbligatoria c'è un
articolo della costituzione l'articolo
33 che dice che l'istruzione
obbligatoria ed è compito dei genitori
la scuola statale è la risposta che
dallo stato ma voi genitori siete
liberissimi di educare ed istruire i
vostri figli come volete
i cambiamenti avvengono sia perché uno
abbraccia la propria volontà abbraccia
la fiducia abbraccia la vita ma anche
perché serve un po di informazione
bisogna sapere quali sono i propri
diritti ei propri doveri
le tre caratteristiche che rendono
speciale la nostra scuola sono la
formazione degli insegnanti il lavoro
che facciamo che le famiglie è
ovviamente tutta la metodologia
organizzativa gestionale dell'approccio
pedagogico che mettiamo in campo
riguardo gli insegnanti io non credo che
l'università sia l'unica garanzia
insegnante professionista
per me per essere un insegnante
professionista bisogna tenere in armonia
quattro elementi chiave la passione e la
vocazione lo studio e la formazione
costante delle qualità umane e morali e
alla fine la capacità la disponibilità a
lavorare su se stessi se manca uno di
questi punti sarà un insegnante poco
efficace scarsamente efficace molto
efficace sotto certi punti di vista e
scarsamente sotto altri quindi gli
insegnanti da noi fanno dei periodi
intensivi a scuola prima di essere
assunti fanno delle osservazioni e
tirocini quindi li esponiamo alla
situazione senza dargli il ruolo
centrale di insegnamento e poi facciamo
tutto un percorso di formazione
parallelo dal punto di vista personale
dal punto di vista pedagogico perché per
fare con i bambini bisogna sapere come
funziona un bambino un bambino ha dei
meccanismi psicologici molto delicati
che devono essere conosciuti tutelati e
preservati prima chiara diceva che
sembra meno da 0 a 12 anni non viene
esposta al linguaggio non riuscirà più a
parlare
beh questi meccanismi valgono per tutte
le sfaccettature dell'essere umano e
avvengono proprio nella parte
dell'infanzia la più delicata e serve
informazione bisogna saperli quali sono
poi con i genitori
noi abbiamo degli assiomi dei punti
cardine quello che i genitori diciamo è
che la scuola non si assume la delega
dell'istruzione e della crescita e tuo
figlio
c'è una corresponsabilità sempre e ci
sono dei punti chiave che l'elenco primo
non puoi chiedere al tuo figlio di fare
quello che tu non sai fare
vuoi un figlio empatico simpatico e un
figlio mobile sia mag il figlio
tollerante si tollerante vuoi un figlio
sensibile quanto sei sensibile te
pretendiamo dai nostri figli che coprano
le nostre lacune
il bambino è diventato un biglietto da
visita poi un'altra regola è che noi
come scuola non risolveremo problemi che
voi non siete riusciti a risolvere come
famiglia
semmai le risolviamo insieme nella
corresponsabilità
noi non li prendiamo
poi quello che diciamo le famiglie è che
ogni disagio di un bambino è sempre un
messaggio a volte il messaggio per la
scuola a volte il messaggio per la
famiglia quando ma meno porta un disagio
noi rivestiamo il ruolo di testimoni
consapevoli significa di persone che
vedono quel messaggio non lo negano
mi stai dicendo questa cosa io ti
ascolto bambini che non vengono mai
ascoltati ricevono il messaggio che
tutto quello che loro pensano non ha
valore che il mondo circostante dal
luogo del quale io non mi posso fidare e
che devo sempre affidarmi agli altri
perché l'informazione che arriva da
fuori è più importante di quello che hai
utenze di me stesso e l'ultima regole
che gerarchicamente viene prima il
singolo la coppia la coppia di genitori
e il bambino ogni qual volta un bambino
al disagio
risaliamo la cascata per capire dove il
disagio nasce quindi se il problema è
del padre o della madre e della coppia
prima che c'era il bambino se della
coppia con il bambino se del bambino non
arriviamo mai al bambino solitamente ci
fermiamo un punto precedente della
cascata i bambini hanno la possibilità
di scegliere tra un ventaglio di scelte
c'è un confine di sicurezza i bambini
hanno bisogno di regole hanno bisogno di
sicurezza all'interno di questo hanno
bisogno di muoversi di sperimentare
quindi bambini che avete visto prima
erano i bambini della scuola materna
tutte le mattine scelgono le attività
che vogliono lavorano in cucina hanno le
capre fanno tutte attività reali nei
primi sei anni bisogni dei bambini sono
reale bisogna passargli la realtà verità
delle situazioni onestà alfabetizzazione
emotiva autonomia nei bisogni primari
ciò fame o sete ciò sono devo fare la
pipì non devono essere indottrinati
infarciti di informazioni perché tutta
l'autonomia culturale di pensiero arriva
successivamente dai 6 ai 12 anni
le 6 12 anni questa è la scuola
elementare quello che succede che ad
esempio i bambini hanno una moneta
interna quando entra una scuola hanno un
reddito di cittadinanza che ci fanno con
i soldi ci comprano le cose che servono
nessun genitore cia la lista della spesa
iniziale 10 colori giornata no
i bambini hanno il negozio della scuola
che ha gestito dai bambini e devono
comprarsi le cose che gli serve
se le devono curare e poi devono anche
per pagarsi tra anzi come fanno a
guadagnarsi i soldi lavorando
all'interno della scuola fanno le
lavatrici cucinano o puliscono lavano
fanno la raccolta e la spazzatura nel
campo poi cosa fanno le recensioni dei
libri fanno tantissime attività e non è
che stiamo giocando all'allegro
imprenditore stiamo cercando di passare
un messaggio che i soldi sono uno
strumento non solo nel fine i soldi sono
anche un riconoscimento del tuo valore
io non ti obbliga a fare le cose ma ti
stimola costruirti una autonomia di
pensiero perché se a tre anni
l'autonomia e imparare a fare la pipì da
soli successivamente l'autonomia e anche
gestirsi il proprio tempo a dargli
valore gestirsi i propri soldi decidere
come investire le proprie energie e
questo è il passo successivo e deve
andare velocissimo perché noi stiamo
lavorando un progetto residenziale
stiamo lavorando un progetto di bambini
che vanno a vivere insieme dai 12 ai 18
anni in una scuola dal lunedì al venerdì
e lavorano e ci sarà il ristorante
interno d'albergo interno e nessuno
pagherà la scuola perché sarà il lavoro
di tutti che permetterà la scuola
diventare un sistema molto poetico che
si rigenera
io qui concludo io la cosa che vorrei
passarvi è che tutto quello che stiamo
facendo
mira principalmente a tutelare l'essere
a tutelare la delicatissima porzione di
esistenza che ogni bambino riceve fanno
nasce la delicatissima modalità di
difesa dagli attacchi esterni dagli
attentati pedagogici che gli adulti
cercano di fare costantemente i bambini
di tutelare il proprio essere senza far
sì che l'essere si confonda con il fare
che sono meccanismi scolastici acquisiti
dove tu sei il tuo voto ovviamente da
noi non ci sono vuoti e dico solo che
nel momento in cui come società ci
renderemo conto che quando parliamo
della società è la società che parla di
se stessa che allora riusciremo a
cambiarla
[Applauso]
[Musica]